first year it sounds like a story
straight out of a holiday Hallmark movie
a mother to be went into labor then went
racing to the hospital but didn't get
there in time she pulled off on the side
of the road to seek the help of
strangers to help deliver her baby but
it wasn't just any strangers and it
wasn't just any road as correspondent
Scott McFarland shows us from Washington
Christina Hansen's baby daughter Quinn
enjoys the long walks in the stroller on
a sidewalk outside the U.S Capitol we
caught up with mom in her new arrival
Washington they weren't just visiting
here we've got some Smiles now
we needed this fresh air Quinn was born
right here Hanson a Washington DC
Elementary School teacher went into
labor one morning this fall and by her
own admission waited a little too long
to head to the hospital
barely into the drive she knew she
wouldn't get there and her head was
coming out my my water broke on the way
Hanson's mom was driving and stopped
outside the U.S Senate after spotting
Capitol police officers then waved them
over for help is that scary
it's definitely scary definitely
expected to be in the hospital
to deliver Quinn Captain carnisha
Mendoza who works in the agency's Civil
disturbance unit ended up being one of
two Capitol Police on the front lines of
this beautifully civil disturbance when
I started talking to her and she told me
her water broke and then she said the
head was coming out so I mean I when
people say um good job congratulations
on delivering the baby I say you know
the baby really delivered herself K-9
inspector Jackie yaniga 14 years on the
job and herself a mom coached and calmed
Hansen and helped a medic cut the
umbilical cord that's probably one of
the best things they've done in my
career which was not expected whatsoever
but a pleasant surprise for the U.S
Capitol staff and Community which last
year saw such ugliness and despair
Baby Quinn brings Joy the officers give
gifts and regularly ask for photos and
mom has a new favorite landmark around
which to walk that stroller you forever
have a story oh forever forever a story
to tell about how this beautiful little
girl came into this world at 11 54 A.M
on Constitution Avenue in our nation's
capital
already making her own history for CBS
Saturday morning I'm Scott McFarland at
the Capitol
now if she ends up in Congress that will
be a story the first female president of
the United States there you go more
babies born on the steps of Congress wow
I love the way Scott refers to it as a
beautifully civil disturbance absolutely